Mary was not at all pleased with her new home.
She was not used to servants talking to her as if they were the same.
"Where is my maid?", Mary asked.
"In India, I had my own maid."
"You won't have one here", Martha said.
With these words, Martha left Mary alone.
There was nothing for Mary to do in the house. So every day, she walked in the gardens.
One day, she walked around the wall without a door.
Suddenly, she heard a bird singing.
Mary asked the bird, "Will you be my friend?"
The bird flew toward a tree and sat on a branch.
It began to sing.
"You live in that garden, don't you?", she said.
"But no one can go in because there isn't a door."
"I want to know what's behind this wall."
The robin trusted her and did not fly away.
It began pecking at the ground, looking for a worm to eat.
Mary looked closely at the ground.
She saw something that looked like metal.
She cleaned it and saw that it was a key.
Mary stopped skipping and spoke to the robin.
"Can you show me where the door is?"
The robin sat on the top of the garden wall.
It began to sing.
Mary pulled at a piece of the ivy.
It came away from the wall.
Behind the wall was a door.
Mary put the key in the lock of the door and turned it.
Only seconds later, Mary was inside the secret garden.